[Musique]
bonjour a tous bien lui dans si on
parlait sport le rendez vous qu'il ne
faut absolument pas manquer si vous êtes
un amoureux du sport local
ils sont quatre autour de cette table
ils vont vous faire rêver ce sont les
chroniqueurs présentation en musique de
ces magiciens du sport local
on commence à ma droite c'est le david
copperfield du cyclisme il se murmure
qu'il arriverait à disparaître sur la
piste tellement sa vitesse est
impressionnante le capitaine le sel
l'unique ya des charriers effet le
plaisir d'être sur cette émission
nouvelle fois quand allez-vous très très
bien alors c'est une rumeur c'est quoi
ce à disparaître sur la piste je
l'aimerais disparaît mais je pense pas
ce soit fait par rapport à la vitesse
j'ai pris une grande claque à courbevoie
pas sur la piste peut-être on ne voit
pas sur la piste en ce moment on ne va
pas en tout cas c'est sûr on en passe de
l'autre côté un musique nour que nous
vous connaissez forcément sa musique il
est de retour sur ce plateau
après quelques émissions d'absence et le
cristiano ronaldo au débat le michael
jordan des punchlines il serait même une
inspiration pour de nombreuses
personnalités dans ce monde comme barack
obama ou leonardo dicaprio pour ne citer
qu'eux le président mustapha larbaoui le
président de l'étoile sportive
le président d'honneur de l'étoile
sportive de trappes est avec nous se
sont un jour bonjour téléspectateurs
c'est mental et vous mais sûrement un
moment après après c'est à apprécier
comme je l'entends dire ouais vraiment
je ne viens d'ailleurs que pour ça et
les téléspectateurs n'attendent que ce
moment là bravo merci
or passe de l'autre côté musique on les
surnomme dans cette émission le zorro
yvelinois ce cavalier international nous
vient tout droit de plaisir il est
également amateur de boxe et
pas à décocher un crochet vers bâle
pendant les débats s'il le faut raul aux
côtés d'autres est avec nous pendant une
heure dans soir mickaël quand avez-vous
raul quant à chaque fois que je siège
autour de cette table aux harcèlements
vous avez réviser vos fiches revenir à 6
du nord vous avez des gros morceaux en
face de bruit à côté de vous yann
dujarrier vous cette femme harbaoui j'en
suis un aussi à droite
musique c'est toujours un plaisir de la
recevoir sur cette émission de nature
gentille douce elle n'hésite pas à
s'imposer quand il le faut comme c'est
le cas dans son sport la pole dance
notre ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange sera avec nous
pendant une heure nouvelle fois je suis
ravi de revenir comme ça même avec
apparemment une espèce de bataille de
testostérone n'y a que des consensus et
en minorité en hausse et par joseph
pacini observé ça va me faire ça va me
faire sourire tout ça c'est bien
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission j'aimerais qu'on revienne à
rapidement sur une course solide qui
s'est déroulé aux clayes-sous-bois ce
jeudi à 1er novembre la deuxième édition
du trail au wynn et quand vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images les cours se sont
pour la plupart déguisés pour participer
à cette course 100% nature sur le thème
d'halloween
au programme un tracé de 19 km un autre
de 10 km départ du parc jean carillon
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
course messieurs dames
mustapha penser c'est d'abord une façon
de faire du sport comme une autre c'est
lié à une activité festive donc c'est
pas plus mal
je préfère ça que de voir éventuellement
des mondes qui foutent le bordel et qui
sont courues qui se font courser par les
flics c'est une autre forme de course
voilà donc à part à part cette à part à
part cette blague j'ai pas grand chose à
dire là dessus c'est ça vous fait du
sport c'est sympa c'est festif faire ça
peut ça fait pas mal au contraire donc
c'est je prends un but vous prenez vous
aussi peu importe de la manière dont on
célèbre un événement marque le moment
celle et les valeurs du sport qui sont
véhiculés gelé je les salue
hélène il faut peut-être créer des
ambiances autour des courses maintenant
il ya tellement de courses qu'il faut
forcément se démarquer oui moi j'aime
bien je trouve que c'est l'occasion en
fait de se rassembler de mobiliser un
peu plus de monde dans des sports que
les personnes ne ferait pas forcément
d'habitude créer des petites cohésion de
groupe comme ça et puis j'ai des
occasions je trouve que toute façon
toute occasion est bonne à prendre pour
pour les faire du sport est une façon
ludique
si andy jarrier vous a pas entendu sur
les quais parce que vous étiez vous
saviez déguisé en fait inspirée non moi
je me dis juste que 19 km et 10 km
costumes en costume c'est pas c'est pas
évident sur des trails alors je connais
pas je connais pas le parcours mais mais
ouais je pense que cette vente de
quelque chose de sympa de sympa à vivre
les prochaines non non non tu vois pas
ce qu'il ya au moins neuf kilomètres 500
je suis en la petite épreuve
en fait il peut les faire mais en vélo
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler à golf et plus
particulièrement de la nouvelle date de
l'open de france de golf le font
également focus sur les jeux olympiques
de 2024 plusieurs épreuves sont menacés
dans les yvelines
mais avant de lui et de développer ces
thèmes on va parler cyclisme dans ce
sens par les sports
on va parler de volley-ball tout de
suite ce sera après le cyclisme tous les
signaux sont au vert pour l'équipe
féminine de vélizy en nationale 3 ce
dimanche 4 novembre les sportives
yvelinoise se sont imposés 3 sets à 0
contre châteaudun le score 25 à 20 25 15
et 25 à 8 avec cette victoire les
vénusiennes conserve la première place
du championnat de nationale 3 devant
argenteuil
mais le premier ne s'enflamme pas on
écoute le coach laurent vernay donc
l'installer c'est une année de plaisir
où maintenant les filles commencent à
chercher justement à faire des résultats
mais les objectifs du club
ici de mode c'est de se maintenir moi
ces dossiers de fallout à bout et plus
ça va et puis fille sont gourmandes donc
on va voir ce qui se passait avant le
match des filles l'équipe masculine
affrontés à saint-avertin sport à
domicile pour le compte de la 6e journée
du championnat de nationale 3 et les
billysiens ont réussi à s'imposer 3 sets
à 1 une victoire qui leur permet de
grimper à la troisième place on écoute
les réactions micro de notre journaliste
patrick jacques de dixmude point c'est
pas mal on a bien servi on a su on a su
tu reprends sur des moments où c'était
un peu un peu compliqué notamment au
bloc on a été on a été assez performant
et
donc voilà le service harris très simple
on a été pas mal et puis de 2 à vélizy
donc on a deux équipes en nationale 3
une équipe masculine à la troisième
place une équipe féminine à la première
place la question sur ce thème le club
de vélizy peut-il conserver deux équipes
de haut niveau en nationale 3 vous votez
oui on voit le classement justement
troisième vélizy sas et c'est l'équipe
masculine voit la beauté
vous avez voté pas mustapha nous avons
voté oui oui tourné a commenté l'agent
ian pourquoi pas parce que moi je suis
ultra chauvin je rappelle que mon club
c'est le cv est donc c'est au cv vélizy
donc levé pour vélizy donc voilà c'est
une commune qui est capable d'avoir ce
type de deux infrastructures
il n'y a pas deux et pas de problème
pour ça je vais je vais m'intéresser
très fortement à ses équipes parce que
en fait je m'entraîne à la salle de
musique est juste en dessous des
terrains qu'on vient de voir et donc la
proximité va faire que je vais à vous je
vais je vais jeter un oeil avec avec
avec grand plaisir le volet c'est aussi
un sport que j'aime beaucoup et donc on
va on va suivre ça avec attention
faut quand même le faire attention parce
qu'on est quand même seulement sur la
première partie de saison
une saison c'est quand même toujours
très non faut pas brûler les étapes
par contre je mets une alerte tout de
suite les filles sont promus viennent de
monter deux montées consécutives
on sait quel est le danger que cela peut
engendrer donc je pense qu'il faut déjà
anticipé si jamais il y à cette montée
qui se produit en fin de saison il faut
faire il faut faire attention pour pas
pour pas que l'année prochaine ce soit
ce soit une catastrophe une catastrophe
nationale de 6,6 si elles montrent si
elle manque l'année prochaine voilà
chaque marché est toujours de plus en
plus hautes
quand on quand on les grave y voilà moi
je mets déjà ou un ring là-dessus cordes
quand j'entends double montée ça me fait
toujours un petit peu peur j'espère que
les dirigeants nous entende en tout cas
on en reparlera hélène vous avez voté
verve aussi du coup pour don pour vous
le club de visite doit avoir deux
grosses équipes quand il ya des bonnes
techniques des bonnes tactiques des des
bons sport fait des bons sportifs et des
bonnes performances n'y a pas de raison
de les freiner faut encourager faut y
aller elles ont des cinq équipes
masculines féminines ont du potentiel
donc il faut faut l'exercer
maintenant je suis assez contente que on
ne choisissent pas spécialement l'équipe
masculine au profit de l'équipe féminine
le sport féminin est assez peu
représenté en général est là
en plus elles sont voilà avant elles
sont premières on a encore comme disait
yann pas mal de moi et de match a offert
vais mais je trouve ça très bien qui est
qui et de groupes équipe à de fins de
les deux catégories qui est pas de faire
voilà c'est ça moustapha à la question
je dirais ils doivent en parallèle
continuer et et assurer leur performance
on entend souvent les coaches dire voilà
on est premier mais on s'emballe pas
mais s'il faut s'emballer un moment
donné il faut y aller ça fait par
l'enthousiaste fait partie du sport
gardez à l'esprit que il faut pas
justement penser qu'on est meilleur qu
on est réellement donc faut continuer le
travail il faut continuer sur les
exercices faut continuer la cohésion des
équipes
bref faut mettre tous les ingrédients
tout le temps mais il faut avoir envie
parce que quand on est premier se dire
que finalement l'objectif c'est le
maintien
personne peut y croire en tous les cas
moi je n'y crois pas et il n'y a pas de
raison de croire en ça parce que le
maintien clairement si son premier jaffe
la façon dont il travaille je vois pas
comment ça peut tomber virgule bien sûr
parce que les esprits chagrins disent
toujours la même chose
faut pas crier victoire fait pas vendre
la peau de l'ours avant de l'avoir tué
tout ça on le sait mais à un moment
donné l'enthousiasmé dans le sport c'est
important l'envy c'est important les
objectifs c'est important on sait tous
que la maladie peut frapper un m les
accidents peuvent frapper les uns les
autres d'avoir des problèmes financiers
et des problèmes au niveau des dires il
peut tout arriver
sauf que quand on est premier et qu'on a
vraiment la méthode la manière les
éléments les joueurs et c'est faux
s'enthousiasmer pour la première place
royale et a failli aller ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que du coup on a
les garçons et les filles d'un club au
même niveau
ça aussi c'est hyper si vous n'en mangez
rarement vu dans le trailer
effectivement aux deux clubs dans les
îles et même en hiver
et à ce niveau là donc je trouve ça
d'autant plus stimulant que c'est pas
une rivalité c'est une stimulation c'est
pas du tout l'idée de se tirer la bourre
parce que moi je suis pas du tout là
dedans contraire donc moi je félicite
les dirigeants et ils doivent faire ça
en parallèle et n'ont pas favorisé une
équipe plutôt qu'une autre
ou se dire que on a peur de favoriser
l'une par rapport à l'autre
ils doivent et je les félicite parce que
c'est vraiment une pour le coup très
belles choses
raul est ce qu a pas un choix à faire
quand même au bout d'un moment surtout
un choix financier forcément une équipe
de haut niveau ça coûte cher
il ya des déplacements et son qui sont
lointains parfois est-ce qu'il faut pas
sélectionner une équipe plus qu'une
autre
alors que les spécialistes du volet me
reprenne si je me trompe mais je ne
pense pas mon propos ce sera un petit
peu la synthèse de deux des trois avis à
savoir que justement le l'envergure de
la de la commune de vélizy permet aussi
cette ce fonctionnement là de par son
énergie et ses moyens financiers pour
rejoindre hélène il est hors de question
de faire un choix par sexisme ça c'est
un de plus anti sport que ça et surtout
je pense que la spirale positive
justement de ce pied d'égalité entre les
hommes les femmes doit doit absolument
être l'instrument principal de de
l'évolution donc non je pense qu'il faut
ou alors faire un choix au dernier
moment mais en tous les cas avoir tout
tenté et rester sur cette idée de ne
favoriser aucune des deux équipes il ya
certains clubs par exemple en basket le
chesnay versailles a favorisé l'équipe
féminine wii party est plutôt que
l'équipe masculine aux coûts
effectivement que l'équipe féminine est
en national
nationale 2 actuellement alors que
l'équipe masculine en prénationale bien
sûr mais c'est qu'au national 3 pardon
pour les comme dans un club où l'équipe
masculine serait beaucoup plus
prestigieuses et performante et ben
effectivement là c'est pas par sexisme
aimé par jeu
choix judicieux que l'on favorise que ça
et dans un sens ou dans l'autre ça une
certaine logique
mais dans ce cas tout à fait particulier
autant profiter de cette belle de cette
belle réussite simultanées vous êtes
d'accord avec ouais je suis complètement
d'accord et je vais même choix
financiers non ne ne rentre pas envie de
chez parce que je connais la connaissent
bien le maire devait de vue généralement
les clubs locaux l'ont pas forcément
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent alors ce qui
ce qui est vrai et les subventions
baissent pour tout le monde ça y'a pas
de et pas de problème et il n'y a pas de
y
c'est une vérité et on peut on ne peut
rien contre maintenant vélizy a quand
même cette facilité mais il ya
énormément d'entreprises et donc on
arrive quand même à trouver des
partenariats et donc à faire de notre
site web et des investisseurs a fait à
faire vivre nos associations
même si c'est un combat c'est un combat
du quotidien maintenant je connais la
politique sportive de vélizy elle n'est
pas du tout élitiste on est on est là
pour pour faire enfin vélizy c'est
vraiment du sport loisir et du sport
pour pour tous si c'est ce que cette
association arrive à avoir ces deux
équipes qui montent et qui gravissent
les échelons petit à petit c'est qu'ils
ont une politique qui qui qui n'est pas
basé sur le résultat mais parce que
c'est pas comme ça c'est pas ce qu'on
leur demande mais simplement ils ont
peut-être eu les moyens ou les bonnes
rencontres ils ont eu les bons
recrutements
voilà toutes ces choses là pour moi
aujourd'hui elles sont encore trop trop
floue mais je vais vraiment m'intéresser
pour pour aller se trouver des
informations et savoir comment est-ce
qu'ils ont monté ces deux projets et
comment est-ce qu'ils vont anticiper la
suite mustapha attrapée est-ce que vous
pourriez mettre les équipes l'équipe
féminine et l'équipe masculine sur le
même pied d'égalité
un jour maintenir les deux équipes au
même niveau comme comme le fait
actuellement
velits alors même si l'équipe féminine
part de plus loin forcément chez vous
c'est d'abord d'abord c'est le cas c'est
à dire que parle d'ambition la
remerciant l'ambition pour moi c'est le
cas puisque j'ai voulu au club de foot
de trappes absolument avoir une équipe
une section pas une équipe féminine au
passage
un club de foot qui est dramatiquement
touché par l'histoire des féminines
puisque c'est le club de montigny qui
historiquement n'avait n'avait fait que
le pari des féminines et aujourd'hui ils
ont de grosses difficultés de
recrutement nous c'est l'inversé on a
une ambition d'avoir des féminines mais
c'est pas simplement l'ambition de voir
des filles ou marketé les filles ou
avoir un budget fille c'est juste que
c'est tellement évident est la preuve
c'est qu'une fois que le choix était
fait on a 150 fils un vrai pro bien
qu'ils aient une demande ça prouve bien
qu'il ya des gens qui veulent on n'a
forcé personne
en revanche il ya l'ambition et ensuite
il faut pouvoir parce que quand je dis
tout à l'heure on doit faire on doit
faire les deux équipes en parallèle on
doit pouvoir également donc le choix
budgétaires il se pose un moment donné
je frapperai qui se posent à ce niveau
là la preuve c'est qu'ils le font
combien de temps ça durera après il peut
y avoir des choix effectivement mais qui
ne sont pas des choix de coeur ni de lui
ni deux ni passion mais a donné deux
raisons certains d'en donner civile les
deniers du club font qu' il faut payer
pour aller en national par exemple et
quand ça sera au détriment d'autres
ça peut être transitoire par contre
l'ambition est l'intérêt de porter les
deux équipes au plus haut niveau c'est
tout le travail qui a fait 1 quand on a
l'ambition et 2c de trouver ses
partenaires qui vont l'accompagner et
franchement pour avoir piloté un club de
lons longtemps quand on a un projet à
proposer de ce type là et je trouve
qu'ils ont un très beau projet ils
auront plein de gens pour les
accompagner alors il peut y avoir des
moments compliqués des choix tactiques
stratégiques pas sexiste parce que c'est
pas je pense pas qu'il ya un président
qui puisse raisonner comme ça je crois
pas mais c'est des choses ça auquel il
faut foncer quand même je pense me
diront qu'ils arrivent à mener ce type
de produits nadal et il va juste pouvoir
en avoir une vraie une vraie
reconnaissance par par sont pas réglées
par ses adhérents
et puis par part par la commune et par
les départements financiers des
féminines j'ai toujours sur staff et
efficace qu on part de loin la culture
du foot chez les fixes et pas ces
raisons la culture du foot en général
ensuite parce que débarque et puis cette
trappe
c'est très mec donc on a su percer on a
su sur staff et on voit aujourd'hui que
ça avance bien succédant les cas tension
en tout cas on range maintenant les
ballons de volley ball et nous allons
passer à notre rubrique focus
[Musique]
coup dur pour l'open de france de golf
l'european tour l'organisateur des
tournois européens a décidé de lui
retirer son statut de rolex series en
2019 faute d'un sponsor assez important
le rendez vous est donc éjecté des huit
tournois du vieux continent on écoute le
dtn christophe muniesa déclassé il ne
sent pas être comment approprié l'open
change de date ses certitudes mais
déclassé il reste toute façon une
épreuve du european tour ça ne vient pas
eu des crocs de chaque jour donc on
utilise en général le terme des classes
et quand une épreuve où une équipe passe
de première division en deuxième
division ce n'est clairement pas le cas
mais c'est pas à l'aune d'une édition
qu' il faut évaluer la valeur d'une
épreuve
il faut essayer de remettre aussi tous
un petit peu en perspective autre
changement le tournoi sera déplacé dans
le calendrier 2010 9 le rendez-vous ne
siégera plus la dernière semaine de juin
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines mais du 17 au 20 octobre
écouter de nouveau christophe muniesa
l'open de france en juin a pu souffrir
par le passé d'une trop grande proximité
de tat avec roland garros où avec le
tour de france ou avec le rôle mondial
de foot
donc on pense qu'en étant placés en
deuxième partie de saison là on a un
coup à jouer si on peut dire
il reste encore une inconnue sur le
prochain open de france la dotation elle
devrait passer de 7 millions de dollars
à un peu moins de 3 millions d'euros
suite à la perte de son statut le
plateau des joueurs devraient donc par
conséquent être moins relevé la question
sur ce thème
est ce que cette annonce signe
la mort de l'open de france oui non
enfin un petit duel entre raul et
mustapha rauf au conseil ça veut dire
distinction de l'événement cesse à
l'extinction ou en tout cas qui termine
je pense proposer dans les couloirs jeu
je m'imagine pas comment une
coordination de golf comme la france
pourrait en venir un jour à revenir à
l'extinction de son nez de son événement
phare je n'y crois pas je pense que il y
aura forcément au bout d'un an une
démarche d'aidé des quêtes de fond pour
que pour redorer le blason de cet
événement alors est-ce qu'il va
connaître un creux de vague pendant de
certain nombre d'années c'est fort
possible voire inévitable mais je
n'imagine pas qu'en france
l'événement phare du golf puisse
disparaître
ce qu'on remarque autour de cette table
c'est qu'on attend à chaque fois de
beaux débats il faut répondre par oui ou
par non
donc on répond pas oui vous faire aimer
dieu mais c'est la règle du jeu
ce qui est bien c'est qu'on peut en
parler parce qu'effectivement on faisait
ça on va on finit par dire la même chose
pourquoi moi quand je dis c'est
l'extinction bah oui s'il ya plus une
thune
il ya plus de golfeurs il ya plus de
golfeurs ya puis l'événement
et encore une fois je parle de l'amour
de cet event c'est déjà un événement qui
est souk aient des répercussions et des
retentissements mondiaux par le
événement national
à ce niveau là c'est l'extinction qui
est toujours un tournoi de golf qui
vivotent avec éventuellement des niveaux
nationaux ou régionaux pour une dotation
à 3 millions d'euros qui vont se
partager l'événement il demeura mais moi
quand je parle d'extinction que je parle
de l'extinction médias du de l'événement
comme on l'a connu
c'est à dire avec des retentissements
une médiatisation importante de grosse
dotation celui-là les morts maintenant
ça vivote wind sa vie votre a toujours
et là où je suis pour le coup on se
mettra d'accord c'est que je ne peux pas
croire non plus qu'on le laissera faire
sauf que comme c'est parti là évidemment
que c'est fini ça que ça devient un
tournoi de golf comme on peut en faire
de grandes entreprises permet à ce
niveau là une grosse boîte peut mettre 3
millions ce matin pour à quelques
quelques joueurs de golf de la manière
dont on parle jusqu'à maintenant
oui c'est fini là on est d'accord c'est
que ça peut pas durer il ya forcément
quelqu'un qui reviendra à hauteur de la
tâche parce que les sponsors existe et
puis surtout c'est fou d'entendre ça
après la raideur cup
c'est fou car qu'on a eu un milliard en
plus de téléspectateurs
un événement 250 me et donc je peux en
parler parce que j'y étais c'était
présent c'était absolument phénoménale
on touche pas les mêmes publics encore
une fois mais on parle bien du prestige
de la france parmi eux précise de ce
sport mais qui a un retentissement pour
la nation de toute façon économiquement
symboliquement tout ce qu'on veut c'est
foods d'avoir cette discussion
aujourd'hui qu'on sorte de la reille
derrière donc on est d'accord
est-ce que c'est pas un autre coup du
trône à leur club pour moi c'est leur
pelle tout cela n'est de les déclasser
du coup l'open de france il ya tout
juste deux semaines à la cfu donc
c'était après l'arrêt grâce à la marque
un coup d'arrêt nasscom juste mais je
comprends pas c'est l'inversé
normalement quand il coupe il faut il ya
plus de mecs ici viennent le soussigné
sont charriées c'est surtout le groupe
chinois à chênée qui avait promis
d'investir pendant l'open de france mais
en trois ans plus deux en option et qui
sont qui finalement n'a fait rôtir au
bout de deux heures sera là c'est ça
donc
en effet il y avait un silence il y
avait un projet qui était titus été mis
en route et on se disait bon on a trois
voire cinq ans peut-être la durée des
deux ans mumia rien crié un crâne en
effet la yahya yahya et puis ça tombe
très rapidement d'un seul coup donc
soudain très proche de la fin de la
nouvelle saison je comprends que les
instances européennes veille se veut
yeux veuille road se retirer parce que
ça leur rappelle toi en fait tu pouvais
mettre la main à la poche pour donner
les 7 millions de dollars mais
finalement à préférer des classes y
voilà
comme c'est l'organisation le comité
d'organisation de la dudh open de france
va mettre les choses en place pour que
l'événement en 2020 on retrouve retrouve
son blason voilà tout simplement il n'y
a pas de problème franchement j'aimerais
le contrat parce que quand on s'engage
sur cinq ans en général on s'engage en
plus de voir notre dossier pour dire que
ce soir on a été juste stretch au bond
pour dire que en l'état bien sûr c'est
subclaquant mort s'est jamais moi on est
d'accord mais en tout mais subclaquant
mais je suis d'accord on va y revenir
tous les oubliés un truc génération et
là ça vous surprend il n'y a pas
d'investisseur pour l'open de france
je pense que investisseurs notamment
français parce que là on parle chinois à
chênée qui avait injecté 7 millions de
dollars l'a finalement mais toute façon
il y avait six heures et a beaucoup
d'investisseurs qui sont finalement des
investisseurs étrangers
donc je pense que ça ira français je
sais pas on verra mais ça va sûrement
venir
ça peut pas ça peut pas s'éteindre comme
ça je ne crois pas non plus je sais que
je dirais que la france finira s'étirait
un pied dans une balle dans le pied
le jour où on n'obtiendra pas un pied
dans la balle voilà c'est une balle dans
le pied le jour où ils ont pondu la loi
evin la loi evin c'est ça ou ils ont
interdit ou à l'alcool de faire de la
publicité donc ça veut dire que tous les
toutes les marques de champagne qu'on
peut avoir en france n'ont plus le droit
de participer
et ça marche énormément après pour le
tabac je suis entièrement d'accord mais
la france voilà le vin tous ces choses
là ont ils ont pu droit de communiquer
ou alors que c'était pour l'histoire des
marques de luxe par exemple qui pourra
investir dans le golfe en connaissant
une image aurait là pour eux aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'ils en ont besoin
c'est ça moi quand je suis allé à reims
le week end dernier et j'ai visité une
cave alors vois pas du tout d'alcool
mais ce que mercy a fait aller
ou à consommer avec modération ce qu'ils
ont fait à l'époque pour pouvoir faire
connaître leur marque c'était énorme
donc je me dis aujourd'hui ils ont des
moyens qui sont colossaux et ils ne
peuvent pas l'utiliser pour faire de la
publicité est utilisé le sport pour
pouvoir promouvoir leurs marques
eh bien je trouve ça dommage et là je me
dis que pour le bien-être et on va en
parler de juste après avec avec beaucoup
d'histoire pas d'accord son histoire de
l'alcool
la promotion du club pour la pub pour
avoir du pognon quand même non non il ya
d'autres moyens
je dis aujourd'hui dans une grosse envie
jeudi où il ya une possibilité un
échange de jets de procéder le côté
luxueux de certaines marques et puis le
côté prestigieux du doigt
sinon parce que c'est partout pas à
faire la promotion des médicaments non
plus et que pour vous la nouvelle date
que pensez vous la nouvelle date 2
octobre c'est aussi pour ça justement
sur un sport d'extérieur de forcément de
décaler de décaler en octobre c'est à
dire une somme
ils ont prévu les golfeurs se jouer
partout sans il ya dujarrier sont
prévues mais sofia doha chez citic
c'est comme ayant le coeur n'y est pas
favorable je trouve que les journées
sont pas les petits sont pas les mêmes
c'est pas la même
même ambiance d'aller d'aller jouer en
juin que que mi-octobre quoi c'est le
no10 le dit c'est en espagne en espagne
venir jouer au faux pas bien joué en
france pas loin du lac cardiaque il ya
moins geek
d'habitude il ya vingt-cinq à trente
mille personnes sur un open de france se
sont penchés sur la même nombre de
spectateurs du coup mustapha jeu et ça
sera peut-être un plus un public de
passionnés
oui là pour le coup je ne saurais pas me
projeter plus que ça moi c'était plus
l'aspect financier qui me pose problème
le décalage au mois d'octobre parce que
je pense que les gens qui regardent
aussi aiment bien voir le soleil on l'a
vu pendant la rider c'était un temps
idéal reste essentiel dans son idéal je
félicite l'organisation parce que dix
ans avant savoir qui les versent dans la
sombre et là et les joueurs est-ce
qu'ils vont se déplacer sur cet opus
du coup dans sa chambre que ça sera
l'avant dernier tournoi européen de
l'année en plus en plus je suis non non
c'est sur ces quelques jours qui
viendront peut-être trop gratter
quelques points en fin de sujet voilà
pour les retardataires et puis oui il
est mort de sa belle mort de franco
j'ai eu marc et c'est ce week-end à
peut-être m'inscrire en tout cas sûr sur
la météorite pour venir la ryder cup
tiger woods s'était plaint du froid lors
de la ryder cup à septembre alors que le
thermomètre affichait en moyenne 20
degrés bon là c'est sûr il faudra plus
allons alors que la température est
prise un ami depuis s'habituer aux et la
california bon l'open de france quand
même a subi un pot pour résumer tout ça
quand même un résumé a subi de nombreux
changements quand même ici joué dans
plusieurs golfs pas seulement le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya différentes dates donc l'open de
france a toujours survécu et survit
depuis 1906 donc c'est le plus vieux
tournoi repères comment résumer ça reste
open on passe maintenant à notre
deuxième focus du jour direction à
plaisir le club de la commune dispose
désormais de deux nouveaux terrains
synthétiques ils ont été inaugurés
mi-octobre la sera ouvert pour les
jeunes de la ville l'autre servira pour
les entraînements et matchs des 600
licenciés plaisir wa coût total plus de
600000 euros des terrains réalisées avec
les derniers standards en termes de
revêtement et qui doivent participer au
développement du club
l'équipe féminine a été créé le fo
plaisir se fixe comme objectif de
retrouver les divisions régionales chez
les masculins
écoutez si quelques réactions c'est
important d'avoir un terrain à des
nouvelles générations qui fait qu'ils
amènent qui amènent des nouveaux joueurs
qui amènent parce que c'est à dire les
parades de nouveaux jeunes qui sont
arrivés s'inscrire
oui c'est très important d'abord qu'on
donne au niveau de l'image de marc
d'avoir un beau terrain la volonté de la
ville s'était également d'avoir un
terrain synthétique aussi ouvert pour
les enfants parce que il ya il ya celui
ci qui est pour le club particulièrement
mais aussi pour les scolaires et puis
nous avons un terrain synthétique sur
lequel nous nous sommes engagés auprès
des enfants pour qu'il soit ouvert en
permanence pour qu'ils puissent venir et
jouer et ça nous semble important pour
les enfants de toute la ville raul
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ces
terrains synthétiques
ah ben moi je suis toujours orientés par
les questions d'environnement donc ses
opposants soleil c'est par mes
convictions du coup que je suis
défavorable à et puis je n'en parle
juste après justement je le disais
précédemment les terrains ont été
réalisés avec les dernières normes ce
qui n'est pas forcément le cas de tous
les terrains utilisés en france l'
agence de sécurité sanitaire a alerté
les autorités sur les risques de cancer
liés à ces pelouse synthétique
la raison les granulats des plus de
pneus utilisés dans le terrain sont la
cause de ces risques de cancer donc la
question sur ce thème doit-on interdire
les terrains synthétiques
oui ou non oui pour mustapha non pour
hélène non non non pas les intervient
vers on laisse berlin interdit et rouge
en attendant je dirais plutôt ça pour
faire un petit duel entre hélène et raul
non messieurs bonjour un tour de table
je trouve les lèvres je trouve que c'est
bien parce que oui on peut jouer toute
l'année sur les mêmes conditions et
c'est très bien par contre je finalement
je vois pas trop l'intérêt par rapport
pour moi le foot il ya vraiment un lien
avec le la nature du terrain les
conditions
moi ça peut être ça peut être le rugby
le mans pour moi il ya vraiment une
relation entre le sport d'extérieur en
plein air avec le terrain on joue donc
ça doit pouvoir bouger tout au long de
l'année donc je suis pas très fan du
fait de recouvrir le sol est bon après
l'histoire de deux des terrains
cancérigènes j'ai encore moins fans pour
le coup mais fut web je pense pas que ce
soit je pense qu'on pourrait s'éviter ça
d'abord il existe le foot en salle
c'est un sport une discipline
complètement complètement à part le foot
en salle peut s'apparenter au basket on
va il faudrait faire du basket à
l'extérieur ça existe aussi pour le feu
en salle le rainbow l'ont fait en salle
le foot en salle donc c'est la pratique
du foot dont on parle donc la pratique
d'un sport qu'elle se fasse à
l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur un moment
donné c'est des conditions de jeu qui
sont importantes ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point on est passé de
100 milles
comment dire on est passé de 100 mille
licenciés foot en france on est à plus
de 2 millions il faut juste qu'on puisse
savoir l'occupation des terrains un
terrain de foot c'est super sauf qu'on
peut pas y jouer longtemps on a un
terrain en herbe attrape peut faire un
match maximum de matches par semaine
peut pas s'y entraîner sinon on laboure
le terrain au quelqu'un qui entre en
joue pas donc si on a choisi de jouer
pour les matchs se font sur herbe
les entraînements se font sur
synthétique donc c'est déjà de pratiques
différentes
troisièmement il ya le nombre quand on a
mille licenciés comme on les attrape
deux terrains de foot donc en
l'occurrence pour le coup maintenant
deux synthétique c'est juste que
l'occupation des sports des stades
c'est plus que le groupe hôtelier bien
connu pour l'occupation des sols on est
à 120 130 % d'occupation donc allemand
devait on en revient à la pratique de ce
sport qui est populaire
beaucoup de monde est un moment donné on
peut pas échouer toute l'année plus
souvent quand ces gorges et dont on peut
pas jouer quand ils n'avaient encore
moins pratique qu'un bref c'est
épouvantable de travailler sur un
terrain de foot en naturel mais qui peut
dire le contraire de cette table est
devant et à la télé qu'il faudrait pas
jouer au naturel personnes qui pour les
produits cancérigènes
personne sauf qu'à un moment donné il ya
une réalité alors le synthétique à savon
a sion g1 expliquer pourquoi pour le
nombre pour la pratique du foot surtout
pour son entraînement mais dès qu'on
peut jouer sur un air on y va lamont est
effectivement d'accord et c'est là où je
suis très très content de ce qui s'est
passé à un plaisir c'est qu'ils ont des
terrains maintenant extrêmement peu
polluant mais pas plus loin pour les
ceux qui pratiquent paul ont tout coup
parce que c'est quand même sur la terre
et sur la terre on absorbe bien les
matières donc pour la terre déjà pendant
pour l'écologie l'environnement c'est
pas bon moi j'ai vu des terrains
synthétiques dans le nord de la région
parisienne pas loin de roissy pour pacy
pour pacy télé pour pas citer les
communes les gens jouer sur des terrains
qui étaient verts à la base qui sont les
premières générations qui sont de cette
couleur et quand on voit jouer et quand
vous jouez vous jouez sur du goudron
vous inhalez du goudron première
génération c'était il ya 15 ans c'était
il ya dix ans et à 20 ans aujourd'hui
nos terrains sont on sent quasiment rien
donc j'imagine très peu d'inhalation je
continue à dire que pour la terre c'est
pas bon il ya des clients lionel
d'ailleurs qui utilisent leur certaines
émissions les progrès et après cette
idée de notions cancérigène à celle
pharmaco qui vous parle sur pareils des
cancérigènes toutes matières bio lui le
chimique ingérés par un corps surtout un
corps étranger c'est toxique et donc ça
peut ça peut induire plein de choses
sauf qu'il faut parler de l'innocuité
quand on parle du dosage quand on parle
de l'inhalation sur le lenglen contre
donc en expérimentation on peut tout
dire
sinon autant qu on arrête tout le monde
parce qu'on est en train de tuer nos
mondes si je comprends bien donc il faut
aller vers quelque chose d'extrêmement
peu polluant faut aller vers quelque
chose qui soit effectivement pas en
termes de toxicité
il faut pas alerté non plus tout le
monde tout le monde sur ce terrain là
parce que on ferait une connerie aussi
bien du jarrier qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
il ya quand même trois mille terrain
synthétique en france 10% des terrains
sont synthétiques maintenant en france
papa tous les fermer non non non pas
tous est fermé et comme le dit moustafa
aujourd'hui on en a besoin pour pouvoir
entrer nos gamins quoi
c'est pas possible là la quantité de
demandes en terme de temps d'occupation
du sol est très important donc on a
besoin de ces de ce type de terrain
maintenant il faut juste trouver là il
fait chanter le gène non mais justement
il faut trouver la solution pour les
rendre les moins nocifs possible il faut
pas cancérigène
tout est cancérigène à certaines doses
c'est la dose qui fait le poison est ce
que le fait de s'entraîner trois quarts
d'heure sur un terrain à l'air libre où
on n'est pas à respirer le truc où j'ai
lancé régine que vous appelez de vos
pots d'échappement dans paris enfin je
veux aujourd'hui aux accessits aidé par
l'institué on parle d'augmentation du
prix du pétrole il faut passer aux
voitures électriques mais je suis désolé
aujourd'hui on n'est pas équipé pour
pouvoir passer aux voitures électriques
des gens qui sur 50 en aiguille il ya
énormément de gens qui vivent en
appartement ne sont pas les appartements
ne sont pas équipés pour la voiture
électrique c'est 25000 pneus pour créer
un terrain synthétique pour pouvoir la
situation sérieuse à balla seck et
synthétiques sont cancérigènes tout le
monde retire ces moments moi le premier
j'arrête de bosser c'est pas normal que
je puisse faire de ces démos sur un an
sur un terrain synthétique cancérigènes
c'est probablement cancérigènes je
prends la matière encore une fois c'est
la dose là le temps y passer mais c'est
pas à mon avis pas que rien
malheureusement pas pire que les
jonctions mulhouse je fais du vélo sur
un vélodrome le vélodrome il est vernis
etc
j'imagine sur tous les fronts
la preuve c'est que celui-ci dernière
génération il commence à être ça
commence à être autre chose
il ya des constateurs justement qu'ils
sont en train ou en bateau la matière d
de mettre en place des terrains en liège
enfin on va trouver de la matière et
solutions et des sons
et une jambe a lancé on peut pas se
passer est en effet il ya déjà des
adhérents donc équipé de jouer c'est
tombé il faut optimiser faire au mieux
parce que voilà les retraités je devrais
pas qu'ils devraient pas réserver au
delà de l'optimisation on les met pas en
conduisant les met pas en danger la
notion cancérigènes c'est dire que la
spartan c'est cancérigène la viande
cuite au barbecue c'est cancérigène et
bagnols tout le poison la dose fait le
poison et c'est le passé qui parle là
pour le coup parce que sa menace tout le
temps alors oui à l'améliorer oui il
faut les protéger mon âme est tous
conscient qu'il a dit on va mettre nos
mômes en danger cette thématique
on ouvre maintenant notre page au coup
de projecteur lui ne roule pas sur du
gazon synthétique avait sur la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
robert marchand qui soufflera sa 107e
bougies dans moins de trois semaines est
sorti de sa retraite sportive le temps
d'une petite heure lors d'un
entraînement le cycliste né en 1911 et
depuis 2010 est détenteur du record du
monde de l'heure dans la catégorie
master ceux des plus de 105 ans avec 22
547 km ce champion était au micro de tv
78 même âge est bon on peut faire encore
quelque chose mais ne faut pas se
laisser aller
les jours on vous assoyez labeouf
fauteuil eh bien vous avez pu vous êtes
foutus taïga mouais je continue tous les
jours que les roses a fait un peu de
culture physique
bien entendu le s'aliène le plus en plus
dur j'ai attrapé la maladie ou savez ce
que c'est la vallée de la meuse donc que
ça l'est pas et l'aide que pensez vous
de ce robert marchand je trouve je
trouve fantastique
déjà on arrivera peut-être pas tous à
cet âge là dans ce cas là on aimerait
mais voilà et danse dans ces
conditions-là cette formule à cette
énergie
et puis ses capacités qui la c1 moi je
trouve ça incroyable c'est une passion
on en parlait tout à l'heure on les
enlève le vélo
c'est pas possible pour lui là on le
voit il monte sur le vélo est c'est
parti
il y va avec frites il alors il faut
noter que cette confiance ne sera pas
homologué par les instances
internationales les structures n'ont pas
voulu endosser la responsabilité en cas
de problème physique on écoute jean
michel richefort son ami et partenaire
il ya toujours un risque qui dit record
10 public dit médias et pour un être
humain ben on va donner le meilleur de
soi même et ce serait dommage que une
nouvelle tentative
puisse le mettre en difficulté
robert et comme tout cycliste n'est pas
à l'abri d'une chute ce serait vraiment
très dommage donc il est préférable de
voir robert venir régulièrement
vélodrome pour son plaisir fait faire
quelques tours de piste et puis
descendre du vélo et dire vous allez je
suis en pleine forme la question sur ce
thème doit-on autoriser robert marchand
a réalisé à des records est-ce qu'il
faut l'autorisé ce qu'on lui interdit
actuellement non oui je m'interdis folle
autorisé ou pas servir interdite après
quand interdite autour il est tombé
autorisée photo résister interdire vous
êtes à rien d'accord d'accord ok surtout
pour cette tous nouveau sur cette
édition
[Rires]
vous savez en corse peut être par vous
vous êtes le seul qui d'abord je suis
pas sûr que la piste soit pas beaucoup
santé aujourd'hui cette émission c'est
si vous parlez santé en temps en temps
j'ai un truc à dire l'accès au 6 mai on
parle beaucoup de synthétique les pisse
leçon il fait chaud il peut d'ailleurs
des émanations de benzène
donc c'est cancérigène le benzène l'est
en tous les cas à part ça bien sûr il
faut interdire sinon c'est quoi on fait
un truc pour la science mais c'est quoi
l'idée on veut je vais finir de répondre
l'idée c'est qu'il ya plein de l
actuelle mais l'idée c'est quoi c'est on
va faire un truc pour la séance d'hier
qu'on veut savoir jusqu'à quel point le
corps humain jusqu'à quel âge
la physiologie encore peut apporter des
performances et on voudrait les noter
quelque part c'est pour l'histoire pour
la postérité pour la science voilà qui
pour lui tout simplement je veux dire à
un moment donné on lui donne les clefs
du vélodrome ils tournent 24 25 c'est
son plaisir c'est pas ça dont je parle
c'est peux t'on à la limite l'encourager
lui à des performances à des records moi
je dis pourquoi faire
donc moi pour lui je dis non mais pour
lui je dis tu paies talent fou tu
continue à pédaler autant que tu veux
surtout qu'avec là il a le sourire et ça
ça fait vraiment plaisir à voir
sinon pour le reste je m'arrête là car
ses lunettes pouvoir faire des records
le mot location de nouveaux records et
de prestations pour vous il faut
l'interdire raul si je crois non non non
je pense que c'est un beau duel
est-ce que 106 ans est pas aussi l'âge
de toutes les libertés
en tous les cas quand j'entends liberté
à condition qu évidemment elles n'ont
peut-être pas sûr sur qui que ce soit
mais moi j'ai pas forcément réglé auprès
de moi même le la loi sur le fait de
donner d'avoir la liberté de donner un
jour la fin à ses jours
est ce que finalement ce monsieur là
c'est pas sur un vélo qui voudrait
mourir
est-ce que
comment on peut empêcher un homme de cet
âge là de de faire ce qu'il a envie et
qu'est ce qu'il a vraiment aujourd'hui
envie de faire autre chose à 106 ans que
ça effectivement il a peut-être des
petits enfants des enfants une famille
qui n'aimerait pas le voir partir mais
bon je pense qu'il ya un bon là on a
cédé pris sa retraite il avait pris sa
retraite au ciné c'est ici quelques mois
qu'est-ce qu'il fait partie de la chine
est ce qu'il est et ce qu'il est
la pièce intégrant d'une d'une machine
comme on dirait médiatique ou alors il
fait ses propres choix ce monsieur là si
c'est le cas si c'est le cas on a eu
aucune barrière ne devait être lui être
imposée 6 et sont les bons choix
ah oui mais j'étais son nom et son libre
choix et des choix encore du coup parle
de record en europe parce que en plus
lui permettent et puis lui permettre
d'écrire l'histoire
ah bah voilà c'est ce que se disent si
c'est pour ça oui pour la science pour
l'histoire pour la postérité cake pour
lui moi je dis que non mais encore une
fois encore une fois il peut pédaler
autant qu'ils aient eu personne va lui
retirer sa au contraire mourir sur son
vélo mes horaires sur les mourir sur les
planches d'un verte c'est pas le souci
on parle de record certes quand on parle
de requins on parle de toute une machine
de guerre qui sont autour de lui parce
qu'il faut homologué il faut des
médecins il faut des tas de choses et ça
va que l'inciter à aller au delà de
soirée des hauts de la semaine au delà
de la vie étrangère qui sont venus pour
le voir pédaler une heure moi j'étais
j'ai dit ouais mais j'étais sûr j'étais
oui bien sûr j'étais là parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est juste
impressionnant le zéro mais il a déjà
trouvé sa vie au vélo a dit en forme en
venant ici que je veux seulement 2
construit chaque semaine
nourrir à chaque sortie pour un départ
maintenant parce que je pratique il se
voit il faut quand même plus europe il
se voit part ça j'ai un ami doit
arrêter le vélo ont dix ans si je ne
vois pas comment on peut autoriser et
pousser une machine face à des notions
de records qui nous regarde que nous
encore une fois on parle d'histoire de
postérité
franchement c'est quoi c'est connaître
les limites de scan être humain peut
faire un stage là franchement moi je
mens pas je préfère le voir sourire
comme il sourit
parler comme il parle pédaler comme ils
pédalent parvient d'enregistrement de
records et de machines au tour j'ai pas
parlé de faire du vélo qui fasse du vélo
tout salut l'on appelle ça quand elle
lui
ce qui veut lui s'est gentiment par
l'interdiction c'est justement c'est
parce que j'imagine qu'il en a fait la
demande
il n'a pas fait la demande c'est l'élu
s'est dit on agit lui ai redit 98 % pour
atteindre 106 en attaque demande il ya
pas de ces justes au niveau physique vu
que c'était chaud n'étaient pas son
genre mais la porte
voilà les lieux c'est en ça que je dis
faut fermer la porte à moins que même
s'il veut demeurer au départ je pensais
que ils vont lui avait refusé
retour en arrière parce que quand on
parle d'interdiction j'imagine que ya
une demande c'est pour ça oui mais
l'interdiction lé avant que tu as et en
gros mais un feu rouge c'est pourtant
interdit de le vérifier
même pas donné sa licence donc je crois
qu 1,6 en un truc dans le genre il n'y
avait pas de défauts sur des sections
soit là ou pas c'est votre dernière page
la rubrique débats
je suis désolé y est géré y est on y va
dans cette page débat nous allons parler
des jo de 2024 la compétition sera
organisée à paris du 26 juillet au 11
août dans les yvelines le dossier à
prévoyez des épreuves de cyclisme au
vélodrome national de l'équitation et du
pentathlon moderne au château de
versailles du golfe au golf national du
vtt sur la colline d'elancourt du bmx et
à lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines et enfin des épreuves sur route
dans la vallée de chevreuse mais le
programme devrait a changé selon nos
informations les organisateurs
envisagent de délocaliser les épreuves
de bmx sur un autre site pour éviter de
construire une piste éphémère les
épreuves de cyclisme sur route devrait
faire seulement le tour de paris non
plus passer par la vallée de chevreuse
et versailles
la question sur ce thème faut-il se
battre pour conserver toutes ses
épreuves dans les yvelines
oui ou non oui tous unanimes non taillé
à un petit duel entre élèves des rôles
pas bon parce que je suis assez partagé
entre le fait trouver des fonds des
financements et puis des infrastructures
pour des épreuves et délocaliser ou pas
enfin je sais pas trop d'avis cette
question il ya derrière vous avez pris
votre nom car je suis autant je suis la
corruption le fait de ne pas construire
une piste éphémère pour le bmx et donc
du coup comme on a déjà celle de saint
quentin en yvelines ici en faire une
adam dans l'ouest dans l'est parisien
qui elle sera permanente et continuera
là je valide complètement maintenant ne
pas faire la route dans la vallée de
chevreuse pour moi c'est une erreur mais
faut nullement feu mais enfin
apparemment pas assez de volume aux
arbitres
oui je vois ce côté de dampierre pareil
pour le coup ils ont 6 ans et charles
c'est obligatoire
ils vont faire quoi enfin juste ok et
l'intérêt l'intérêt pour les pour les
spectateurs il et pas seulement sur les
paysages d'eau tour il est sur un
intérêt de la course et mais bien sûr il
est sur la route et si on nous fait une
un circuit autour de paris on va faire
quoi on va voir quoi à la rigueur des
monuments fait le déplacement même avoué
d'accord on va connaître on connaîtra la
connaître à la fin du film au départ de
là au départ de la course ce serait une
arrivée au sprint et basta maintenant
c'est passé à l'intérêt d'intérêt c'est
qu'on ait une vraie bagarre
on a eu un championnat du monde
magnifique avec un parcours un parcours
phénoménal
là il faut mettre dans la baie de
chevreuse il faut qu'ils passent de le
château de ben non la côte du château de
la madeleine il faut qu'ils passent par
là faut que j'en ai partout sur le
circuit bien sûr faux il ya plein de
choses à faire sur dans la vallée de
chevreuse mais il faut se donner les
moyens de fausses de celle de faire
parce qu'ils sont les périphériques cela
pour qu'on dise qu'ils rejetaient les
ferries que pour calmer ou caché que
vous recherchez
c'est une blague mais pas définitif et
que même les yvelines ont conduit en
2001 le marathon de paris lé marathon le
marathon des jo là bien sûr ils
passeront devant les monuments
bien sûr le le camp qui s'appelle le
triathlon se prête à montrer les
monuments n'est pas la course sur route
non pas la course sur route
raul qu'est ce que vous en pensez
puisque en tous les cas sur cette partie
de l'émission tout le monde a l'air de
parler un peu de son sport en ce qui me
concerne moi j'espère que toutes ces
instances qui seront je reviens sur
l'équitation parce que nous le sujet
n'est pas clos non plus en ce qui
concerne versailles ce qui me
chagrinerait beaucoup faire simplement
confirmé à 90
toutes ces instances qui veulent
s'arracher justement les mérites des
retombées corrompt le les jeux
olympiques mettront leur leur fierté de
côté et et feront un choix au service du
sport et est élu es et du prestige que
va représenter l'organisation des jeux
olympiques en france l'équitation à
versailles horaires d'entrée non plus et
ça non il faut arrêter quoi ça c'est
l'équitation à versailles c'est
l'événement l'emplacement place maurice
lacombe fait pour ça bien sûr c'est
insuffisant surtout quand on sait que là
le le débat nenê n'est en fait que le
fruit d'une d'une guéguerre entre la ffe
qui était pas au courant avant avant le
dodo chez votre maladie at home en
hausse de 50 ans des villes des épreuves
fiscale et du golf national philologie
cours du vtt sur la colline d'elancourt
ok j'entends que pour le bmx
mais pour le vélo pour la course sur
route ce n'est pas recevable qu'elles
soient faites ailleurs que charles avait
les cheveux ce serait tellement fou
d'ailleurs de construire un truc aussi
éphémères ça coûte des ronds on peut les
mettre ailleurs
on va améliorer les terrains
synthétiques sur dick l'histoire pour le
bmx
ils ont construit une piste de bmx
mustapha piste bmx qui n'est pas aux
normes en fête olympique car il ya un
toit et ça empêche les diffuseurs de
pouvoir filmer sur le dessus de la piste
du fou par conséquent ils sont obligés
d'en construire une autre
cinq cents mètres plus loin on devrait
pas
dans l'île des loisirs saint quentin en
yvelines qui serait du coup éphémère et
permet un faux car le site et j'entends
qu'on puisse se dire eh ben pour les jo
on va en faire une chaire l'ouest
parisien
il ya largement en termes de quantité de
club de bmx il ya largement de quoi
faire sur l'ouest parisien
et si pour l'intéressé de la couvrirons
la couvrir un après dans le projet on
fond monte pour que la couverture soit
faite après c'est un souci parce que en
effet on a besoin de structures
couvertes pour pouvoir pratiquer le
sport a certainement fin a selon toutes
les conditions climatiques
d'où l'expression couvrir l'événement
sauf que là en l'occurrence voudraient
découvrir le slam
les images sont tellement belles quand
on quand on les voit duo sur pour le bmx
je peux je peux je peux comprendre mais
pourquoi pas mais dans ces cas là est
peut-être ne l'aurait aussi de démonter
tout doit aussi pour filmer ou démonter
le toit bien sûr et apparemment ça n'a
pas été envisagé une vidéo carbone de
toute cette opération ça fait beaucoup
pour faire plaisir au caméraman quand
même on a on a une piste est découvert
on se débrouille tu me des caméras à
l'intérieur on construit nulle pa on
comprend pas d'hélico qu'on a un bilan
carbone plus juste n'oubliez pas de
venir faire un petit tour dimanche au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on organise une très belle épreuve
le grand prix 2010 le grand prix de
vélizy et il est nommé membre de
l'équipe de france qui seront présents
pour un très beau tournoi de keirin et
du haut niveau aussi dans les courses en
1re 2e et 3e cat c'est le 11 novembre
c'est dimanche dimanche qui vient
dimanche 11 novembre tout à fait c'est
ça exactement
je précise quand même que toutes ces
informations sur les jeux olympiques ne
sont pas encore avérées pour l'instant
ce sont juste des discussions
voilà les décisions seront prises un
petit peu plus tard alors avant de
refermer cette émission une mauvaise
nouvelle le skipper louis burton ne
verra pas à la guadeloupe le sportif a
dû abandonner ce mardi à 6 novembre sur
la route du rhum il a été victime d'une
avarie après seulement à 10 heures après
son départ de saint malo alors qu'il
était 4e chez les imoca la raison une
poulie situé dans le puy de foil s'est
arrachée et a fait un trou de 30 cm dans
son bateau après avoir tenté de réparer
à roscoff en bretagne il a dû se
résoudre à abandonner
louis burton visé pourtant la victoire
ou au minimum un podium
la question sur ce thème doit-il être
fataliste par rapport à cette situation
oui c'est finalement se dire c'est comme
ça il emprunte technique
ce qui doit être fataliste face une
fatalité par rapport à mon avis il est
victime
il a été mon bateau est ce que ces deux
bateaux de gagner là
ah le vendée globe à la cbc gagner le
vendée globe donc souligner c'est que
c'est tragique
j'attends de préparation sachant que tu
vas partir pour tant de temps sur des
éléments sur un sport qui passionne les
petits fait dix heures tu dégages à
10h15 des psychoses me dire comment
s'égrener psychologiquement quand on se
prépare justement pensez-vous des mois
et des mois pour finalement un point
abandonné 10 heures plus tard devrais je
faisais là je pense que maintenant je
reviens et qu'il ya il est indépendante
il est indépendant de nos choix
stratégiques et de notre performance et
de nos connaissances en terme de
navigation
je pense que ça aide a justement
rebondir et à dire que finalement il a
été victime du du sort et du ciel enfin
tous les cas de la mer en l'occurrence
mais ma pensée on sait pas exactement ce
qui s'est passé c'est ça le scar dans
l'histoire c'est qu'on ne sait pas ce
qui s'est passé
il a vu tout simplement un trou de 30 cm
dans son bateau avec de l'anglo qui
s'engouffre et on ne sait pas bien ce
qui s'est passé il ya tellement lui le
second de dengue dans l'eau qui avaient
dû croiser une bouteille mais un mot
d'amour doyer dujarrier enfin quand ils
sont au départ de ce type d'épreuve
ils savent que la seule chose qui fait
qu'ils n'arriveront pas au bout c'est la
casse mécanique
voilà non ça fait partie du sport c'est
un sport mécanique en effet pas de
moteur le seul moteur c'est eole
mais ils le savent que ça va que la
seule chose qui vous empêchera d'arriver
au bout c'est la casse mécanique
physiquement ils sont prêts ils savent
que quand ici sur une saison ils doivent
faire trois quatre courses pas sur ces
trois quatre courses il y en a une qui
ne termineront pas dommage c'est
certainement la plus prestigieuse sur
les télés et à lille il était aligné
cette année mais il était surtout favori
mais bien sûr c'est qu'il ya un bateau
donc mai
on est d'accord c'est des super super
pros comme tous les pros ça chante
toujours à tout un professionnel de foot
ce qui peut avoir un problème en allant
en boîte de nuit
schwan pas vrai tout arrive dans la vie
ce que je suis pour moi ce que je suis
en train de dire c'est que le mec il a
préparé
résultat au lieu des années de savoir ce
qui est bien sûr le cavalier peut tomber
de cheval avec le haut jamais remettre
les pieds sur on sait ce niveau là qu'il
peut tout arriver ils sont préparés à
tout on est d'accord sauf que là les
mettre c'est comme il poireaute en 2001
ils font le départ escale escale à
genève ils le savent je sors c'est tous
les dimanches pour eux là c'est une fois
par an voire toute la quatre-voies une
fois dans une vie
donc cette préparation intense qui les
emmène quand même sur des émotions un
peu particulière fait que je peux pas
imaginer qu'on peut de 10 heures ça soit
pas un drame dans sa tête que ça dure
dix minutes que ça dure une heure donc
ça dure trois jours
mais bien sûr que ça va faire rebondir
bien sûr qu'il va se reprojeter dans
l'avenir parce qu'ils sont compétiteurs
je vous dis simplement que le mec comme
ça lui est arrivé au bout de dix heures
tu pouvais pas m'en donnait encore un
petit peu là de trois jours on est quand
même sur l'aura mais la probabilité fin
de troisième dans les cieux franchement
moi à sa place à faire ces marais au
bout de dix heures un commando au bout
de dix jours et que le débat est ouvert
il reste quand même un ebe nohant maire
éric bellion qui à l'heure où l'on
enregistre cette émission 14e du
classement dans la catégorie des bateaux
hors catégorie gistau l'apprentissage
continu et leeds armée de libération car
ces heures catégorie c'est du très très
bon là c'est ça non plus petits battent
l'accord il un bateau à voile avec rôle
à l'ancienne et la fin de cette émission
on se retrouve le 21 novembre prochain
pour une nouvelle émission va terminer
par une citation du nageur américain
mark spitz si vous échouez à vous
préparez vous préparez à échouer je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]